Hablemos un poco sobre los sólidos metálicos.
Y aquí hay un ejemplo de cómo se ve un sólido
metálico: tienden a ser brillantes como éste,
algunos dirían lustroso. Algunos de ustedes
podrían pensar que tal vez sea algún tipo de
aluminio o plata, pero resulta que esto es sodio,
nuestro viejo amigo sodio, que vimos uniéndose
con cloro para formar cloruro de sodio y sodios
iónicos; también puede unirse consigo mismo con
enlaces metálicos. Podrían pensar que esto que
está aquí es plata o algo así, pero en realidad
resulta que es calcio. Y sé lo que están pensando:
¿no es el calcio un tipo de polvo blanco
calcáreo? Bueno, no, esos son compuestos
formados con calcio, como el óxido de calcio. Pero
esto justo aquí es calcio puro, y la razón por la
que tiene que estar en este contenedor es porque
es altamente reactivo con el oxígeno, así que no
hay oxígeno en el contenedor sino algún tipo de
gas inerte. Pero cuando el calcio sólo se une
consigo mismo mediante enlaces metálicos, de los
que hablaremos en un momento, también se ve algo
similar, con este aspecto brillante metálico
o lustroso. ¿Y qué creen que es esto? Bueno,
esto es algo que estamos acostumbrados a asociar
con metales: esto es oro; pero una vez más pueden
ver que tiene esta propiedad brillante. Entonces,
¿qué tienen los metales o los sólidos metálicos
que les permiten ser brillantes de esta manera
y tener otras propiedades que estamos a punto
de ver? Y para entender esto, sólo tenemos que ver
la tabla periódica de los elementos. Y la mayoría
de los elementos de la tabla periódica es en
realidad alguna forma de metal. Tenemos en rojo,
justo aquí, este grupo de elementos, sin
incluir hidrógeno, estos son metales alcalinos,
y por acá están los metales alcalinotérreos, los
metales de transición, los metales posteriores
a la transición, los metaloides. Realmente, sólo
esto que vemos en amarillo y azul no son metales.
Entonces, ¿cómo se forman los metales sólidos
cuando sólo tenemos una muestra pura de ellos?
Bueno, la idea general es que, por ejemplo,
los metales alcalinos todos tienen 1 electrón
de valencia, y para tener una capa externa estable
es mucho más fácil para ellos regalar ese electrón
de valencia. Y es por eso que a menudo vemos que
estos elementos participan en enlaces iónicos;
se puede minimizar con bastante facilidad, pero si
tenemos una muestra pura de ellos pueden aportar
electrones a un mar de electrones, uno cada uno.
Estos metales alcalinotérreos tienen 2 electrones
de valencia, también pueden ser ionizados o, si
hay una muestra pura como en el calcio, cada átomo
de calcio puede contribuir con 2 electrones de
valencia a un mar de electrones. Y los metales
de transición aquí, tienen una capacidad similar
para contribuir con electrones de valencia,
y en general podemos ver que los sólidos
metálicos tienen cationes, estos cationes
cargados positivamente en un mar de electrones.
Entonces tenemos todos estos electrones aquí.
Dibujaré todas estas cargas negativas en las que
se encuentran. ¿De dónde vienen esos electrones?
Bueno, si tuviéramos metales alcalinos, cada uno
de esos átomos podría aportar 1 electrón a ese
mar, porque realmente no quiere ese electrón
de valencia. Si estamos hablando de metales
alcalinotérreos, cada uno podría aportar 2
electrones a ese mar. Ahora que tenemos esta
carga positiva en este mar de electrones,
¿qué piensan acerca de las propiedades?,
¿qué tan bueno creen que será esto en la
conducción de electricidad o calor? Y muchos de
ustedes podrían adivinar que si vemos un cable,
los cables están hechos de metales, porque son
excelentes para conducir electricidad o tienden
a ser excelentes para conducir electricidad,
porque tienen todos estos electrones que pueden
moverse. Y si aplicamos un voltaje, comenzarán
a moverse y conducirán electricidad. Estos
electrones también pueden ser buenos para conducir
energía térmica o calor. Ahora, ya hablamos de que
tienen la propiedad de ser brillantes y lustrosos,
¿pero qué tan fácil sería doblarlos? Hablamos
antes de sólidos iónicos, mencionamos que
pueden ser fuertes pero quebradizos, tan pronto
como tratamos de cambiarlos un poco se pueden
romper. Pero, ¿qué creen que va a pasar aquí
si empujo muy fuertemente esta parte superior
hacia la izquierda? ¿Creen que esto se quebrará o
creen que será maleable o fácil de doblar? Bueno,
si tenemos un sólido metálico puro, en realidad
será bastante maleable; si sólo tomo esta parte
superior y la empujo hacia la izquierda de esta
manera no pasa nada, tenemos esos cationes que
todavía están en ese mar de electrones. Y esto
generalmente se cumple para los sólidos metálicos,
son muy maleables, no son quebradizos; de hecho,
tanto es así que muchas veces queremos que sean
un poco más rígidos, queremos que sean un poco más
duros. Y es por eso que hacemos cosas como agregar
otros elementos al sólido metálico. Por ejemplo,
el hierro puro es razonablemente maleable,
pero si queremos hacerlo más fuerte podemos
pegar átomos de carbono en el medio, por ejemplo:
podría poner un átomo de carbono allí, un átomo de
carbono allá, y de esa manera interrumpir un poco
el mar de electrones para que no sea tan maleable,
será más fuerte y más rígido. Por el momento
dejamos aquí el tema. Esto es sólo una extensión
de lo que ya hemos aprendido sobre metales y
enlaces metálicos, para que se den cuenta de
por qué la mayoría de los elementos de la tabla
periódica que nos son familiares tienen algunas de
estas propiedades cuando están como sólidos puros.